ministers excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
what an inspiring speech and indeed
such an inspiring speech and
hope raising speech against the backdrop
that every day
we see the devastation brought by Russia
to Ukraine
the people of Ukraine are enduring every
horror from every direction from the sky
fire Reigns
from the ground they watched that town
sink underwater
Russia fires missiles at innocent
civilians
for no other region reason than one
man's delusional attempt
to restore a Lost Empire
but every day we see also something else
and that is what I witnessed firsthand
when I last visited the country just
over months ago I saw a country that
does everything possible to Rise From
the Ashes of the world
everyday ukrainians show us what they
are fighting for and what they are dying
for
they show it on the battlefield
they show it on their streets
they show it in the classrooms
they are fighting for their future
for Ukraine free from Russian Invaders
for Ukraine that decides its own destiny
for Ukraine rebuilt and revitalized
in just over a year
ukrainians have cleared rubble from 2
000 kilometers of Roads we built over 40
Bridges
renewed 900 train stations and they pose
and all of this while fighting a war for
their own Survival
but ukrainians are not just restoring
what used to be
they show us how they already reshaping
their country
ukrainians are re-imagining their future
amidst all the lust the pain and the
suffering
let me tell you about European School
number 17.
shrapnel damaged the school's roof
destroyed its walls broke all its
windows and destroyed the heating system
and so when children came back to their
lessons
they did so in unimaginable cold until
a local NGO stepped in with a simple and
creative solution
they installed solar panels on the roof
so children could learn in warmth
this small but meaningful use of clean
energy
to revitalize everyday life
is just one example of how Ukraine is
not just rebuilding but re-imagining
itself
Ukraine has stunned us
with The Bravery
they have inspired us with ingenuity
and they have ordered us
with the way they are transforming their
country in pursuit of their dream
and dear friends it is this stream
of a cleaner Greener more modern Ukraine
that will be the lasting Legacy of this
atrocious War
and it is our responsibility
to make it happen
because ukrainians are fighting not just
for their sovereignty but we've just
heard it also for us
for our values
for our freedom
for our democracies
we can never match their sacrifice
but we can
and we do all Stand United coordinated
and resolute
that Ukraine must win will win and has
our support
not just for as long as it takes to
secure peace
but for a country they are imagining a
country that attracts foreign investment
a country that is master of its future
a country that is a member of the
European Union
[Applause]
together
we will support Ukraine not as
individual Nations but as a coordinated
Community
organized under Innovative platform
a platform that will Channel support to
the reforms and priorities that will
make imagination reality
Together We Get Together We Gather here
to tell ukrainians that their dream is
also our dream
in January we all created the so-called
multi-agency donor coordination platform
it is a first of its kind in the history
of international Aid
it brings together Ukraine
the G7
the European Union the European
Investment Bank
the European bank for reconstruction and
development
the IMF and the World Bank
it creates a single focal point for
international donors
to guarantee that support goes exactly
where Ukraine needs it most
the European commission is contributing
18 billion euros already this year
and together with other donors we closed
ukrainians budget gap for 2023. so that
Ukraine can continue to pay salaries
pensions and for example for their
health care
this is for Ukraine's immediate needs
but let's talk about the future
I believe the European Union has a
special responsibility
and the reason is simple we heard the
president
ukrainians tell us that when they
imagine their future
they see Europe's flag flying over their
cities
and I have no doubt that Ukraine will be
part of our Union
so today
I want to announce two new steps
the first is about Ukraine's reforms
and its path towards EU membership
despite the war Ukraine has accelerated
its reform agenda with impressive speed
and resolve
we in the European Union want to match
efforts and dedication
and this is why today the European
commission presents a new oral update on
the progress Ukraine made on Judiciary
form on anti-corruption on new laws for
media freedom and international
minorities for example
with these reforms
Ukraine also sends a powerful message to
private investors
they will get the transparency
the fairness and the functioning
institutions they need to invest in
Ukraine
and this is especially important because
we need the private sector to step into
because it is you the private sector
with your invaluable expertise and your
financial Firepower that will help
Ukraine realize its dreams
you're here today at this conference and
we really need you and we know we can
rely on you
and that brings me to my last point
we want to match Ukrainian reforms with
European Investments
for every step Ukraine takes towards us
the European Union must take a step
towards Ukraine
yesterday
the European commission proposed to
create a new facility for Ukraine
within the budget of the European Union
it will ensure constant financial
support till 2027.
the facility will be financed in three
ways
with grants from the European budget
with loans raised on Capital markets
and eventually with proceeds from the
immobilized Russian assets
we will come with a proposal for these
assets before the summer break because
the perpetrator has to be held
accountable
[Applause]
now what are the estimated needs
until 2027
Ukraine's remaining fiscal Gap is about
60 billion euros
the needs for fast recovery on top
are about 50 billion euros
that makes in total
110 billion euros until 2027 that are
not covered
therefore yesterday I proposed to EU
member states
to cover 45 percent of this Gap this is
in total 50 billion euros for Ukraine
and we will work with Ukraine on a
corresponding plan and we heard the
first outlines of the planet more
details will come today for Investments
and reform
this plan could become an anchor for all
International donors including the
private sector you need predictability
you need Clarity you need transparency
this will help our coordination and will
maximize our impact and this is what I
mean when we say we are with Ukraine for
as long as it takes
ladies and gentlemen
Putin shattered peace on our continent
on February 24th in 2022.
but he triggered also Ukraine's Journey
towards its dream
and it's our job
and our duty
to the ukrainians who've paid the
ultimate sacrifice
that we unsure
that this re-imagined future becomes
reality
Brick by Brick
house by house
school by school
together we are by Ukraine's side for
the Long Haul Slava Ukrainian
well hello everybody and as you all know
nearly 16 months ago Russian troops
launched a brutal Invasion that has
brought Terror Bloodshed and anguish to
Ukraine and to its people
Russia's actions are not only a vicious
assault on a Sovereign Nation determined
to choose his own path they're also an
attack on the international
rule-based order that is underpinned